We're asked to select which
fractions add together
to make 25 over 22, or 25/22.
You can use as many
fractions as you need.
Put all unused fractions
into the trash can.
So let's think about
how we could do this.
So I actually want to use
the largest fraction first,
just so I can get pretty close.
So I'm going to make 16/22.
And let's see, if
I add 8/22 to that,
then that's going to get me
to--let's see, 16 plus 8,
that gets me to 24/22.
This is 16/22 plus 8/22
is going to get me 24/22.
And if I get one more,
that gets me to 25/22.
And then I could put these
unused ones down here
in the trash can.
So I'm going to put these
unused ones down here.
And let's actually
check our answer.
Got it right.
And there's multiple
ways that we
could have actually done this.
Actually, it's not clear
that there's multiple ways
that we could have done this.
Let's see-- is
there any other way?
Yeah, because even if we
did the 2 and the 4 here,
we would have to get to-- let's
see, 8 would get us to-- this
is 2/22 plus 4/22
is 6/22, plus 8/22
is going to be 14/22, yeah.
And then if you put 16/22,
there's going to be too many.
So actually, the way
we did it was the way
that you've got to do it.
So the 2 and the 4 I'm going
to put in the trash can.
And 16 of something plus 1 of
something plus 8 of something
is going to be 25
of that something.
And in this case, the something
that we're talking about
are 22nds.